is there a stretch of road that's like
nice and clean
and then there's like cities with
difficulties in them that you kind of
think of as the canonical problem to
solve here right uh so starting with the
car side um
well waymo very intentionally picked the
phoenix area and the san francisco area
as a follow once we hit driverless where
when you think of consumer
transportation and ride sharing you know
kind of economy a big percentage of that
market is captured in the densest cities
in the united states and so really
pushing out and solving san francisco
becomes a really huge opportunity and uh
importance and um
and
you know places one dot on kind of like
the spectrum of like kind of complexity
uh the phoenix area starting with
chandler and then like kind of expanding
more broadly in the phoenix
metropolitan area it's i believe the
fastest growing city in the u.s it's a
kind of a higher medium-sized city but
growing quickly
and still captures a really wide range
of kind of like complexities and so
getting to driverless there actually
exposes you to a lot of the building
blocks you need for the more complicated
environments and so in a lot of ways
there's a thesis that if you start to
kind of place a few of these kind of
dots where san francisco has these types
of unique challenges dense pedestrians
all this like complexity especially when
you get into the downtown areas and so
forth and phoenix has like
a really interesting kind of spectrum of
challenges maybe you know other ones
like la kind of add freeway focus and so
forth you start to kind of cover the
full set of features that you might
expect and it becomes faster and faster
if you have the right systems in the
right
organization to then open up the fifth
city in the 10th city in the 20th city
on trucking there's uh some more
properties where um obviously there's
uniquenesses and freeways when you get
into really dense environments and then
uh the real opportunity uh to then you
know get even more uh value is to think
about how you expand with like some of
the surface street challenges but for
example right now we're looking um we
have a big facility that we're uh
finishing building in q1 in uh dallas
area um that'll allow us to do testing
from the dallas area on routes like
dallas to houston dallas to phoenix
going out east and dallas to austin uh
austin so that triangle um waymo should
come to austin
well waymo the car side was in austin
for a while yes i know
come back yeah but uh trucking is
actually texas is one of the best places
to start because of both volume
regulatory weather there's a lot of
benefits
on trucking a huge opportunity is port
of la going east so in a lot of ways a
lot of the work is to start to stitch
together a network and converge to port
of la where you have the biggest port in
the united states
and the amount of goods going east from
there is pretty tremendous and then
obviously there's you know kind of
channels everywhere and you have extra
complexities as you get into like snow
and inclement weather and so forth but
um what's interesting about trucking is
every single route segment that you add
increases the value of the whole network
and so it has this kind of network
effect and cumulative effect that's very
unique and so there's all these
dimensions that we think about um and so
in a lot of ways dallas has a really
unique hub that opens up a lot of
options has become a really valuable
weber so the million questions i get
asked first of all
you mentioned level four
for people who totally don't know
there's these levels of automation
that uh level four refers to uh
kind of the first step that you could
recognize as fully autonomous driving
level five is really fully autonomous
driving level four is kind of fully
autonomous driving and then there are
specific definitions depending on who
you ask what that actually means but
for you what does the level four mean
and you mentioned freeway let's say like
there's three parts of long-haul
trucking maybe i'm wrong in this but
there's freeway driving
there's like
truck stop
and then there's
more urban-y type of area so which of
those do you want to tackle which of
them do you include under level four
like well how do you think about this
problem what do you focus on where's the
biggest impact to be had in the short
term
so the goal is to we get we got to get
to market as fast as we can because the
moment you get to market you just learn
so much and it influences everything
that you do
and it is um
i mean one of the experiences that
carried over from before is that you add
constraints you figure out the right
compromises you do whatever it takes
because getting the market like is so
critical right and here with autonomous
driving you can get to market in so many
different ways that's right and so one
of the simplified simplifications that
we intentionally have put on is using
what we call transfer hubs where you can
imagine
depots that are uh
at the entry points to metropolitan
areas like let's say dallas like the hub
that we're building which
does a few things that are very valuable
so from a first product standpoint you
can automate transfer hub to transfer
hub and that path from the transfer hub
to
the
you know the full freeway route can be a
very intentional single route that you
can select for the features that you
feel you want to handle at that point in
time
now you build the hub
specifically designed
for instruction and that's what's going
to happen actually like and you get you
need to come out in january and check it
out because it's going to be really cool
it's the not only is it our main
operating um headquarters for our fleet
there but it will be the first uh fully
ground up designed driverless hub for
autonomous drivers autonomous trucks in
terms of where do they enter where do
they depart how do you think about the
flow of people goods everything it's
like it's quite cool and it's really
beautiful on how it's thought through
and so early on it is totally reasonable
to do the last
five miles manually to get to the final
kind of depot to avoid having to solve
the general surface street problem which
is obviously very complex now when the
time comes and we are increasingly
already we're pushing on some of this
but we will increasingly be pushing on
surface street capabilities to build out
the value chain to go all the way deeper
to depot instead of transfer hub the
transfer hub and we have probably the
best advantages in the world because of
all the waymo experience on surface
streets but that's not the highest roi
right now where the highest roi is
hub the hub and get the routes going and
so when you ask what's l4
l4 can be applied to any domain
operating domain or scope but it's
effectively for the places where we say
we're ready for autonomous operation we
are one hundred percent operating uh
with uh through the as a self-driving
truck with no uh human behind the wheel
that is l4 autonomy and it doesn't mean
that you operate in every condition it
doesn't mean you operate on every road
but for a particularly well-defined area
operating conditions routes kind of
domain you are fully autonomous and
that's the difference between l4 and l5
and most people would agree that at
least any time in the foreseeable future
l5 is just not even really worth
thinking about because there's always
going to be these extremes
and so it's a race and a almost like a
game where you think of what is the
sequence of expanded capabilities that
create the most value and teach us the
most and create this feedback loop where
we're building out and unlocking more
and more capability over time i got to
ask you just curious so first of all i
have to when i'm allowed to visit the
dallas facility because it's super cool
it's like robot
on the giving and the receiving end it's
the truck is a robot and the
the hub is a robot yeah it's got to be
very robot friendly so yeah that's great
i will feel at home uh the what's the
sensor suite like on the hub if you can
just high level mention it is
does the hub have like lidars and like
is is is the truck doing most of the
intelligence or is the hub also
intelligent yeah so most of it will be
the truck and uh everything is like
connected like so we uh we have our
servers where we know exactly where
every truck is we know exactly what's
happening at a hub and so you can
imagine like a large back-end system
that over time starts to manage uh
timings goods delivery windows all these
sort of things and so you don't actually
uh
need to um there might be special cases
where that is valuable to equip some
sensors um in the hub but a majority of
the intelligence is going to be on the
truck because um
whatever is relevant to the truck uh
relevant should be seen by the truck and
can be relayed
uh remotely for any sort of kind of
cognizance or decision making but
there's a distinct type of workflow
where
where do you check trucks where do you
want them to enter what if there's many
operating at once where's the staging
area to depart how do you set up the
flow of humans and human cars and
traffic so that you minimize the
interaction between humans and kind of
self-driving trucks uh and then how do
you even intelligently select the
locations of these transfer hubs that
are both
really great service locations for a
metropolitan area and there could be
over time many of them for a
metropolitan area
while at the same time leaning into
the path of least resistance to lean
into your current capabilities and
strengths so that you minimize the
amount of work that's necessary to
unlock the next kind of big bar
you